a record number of migrants coming
across our border with mexico this year
the biden administration plans to lift a
covet era health order known as title 42
although last week a federal judge put
it on hold republicans and democrats
have said it will allow even more people
seeking asylum to come into the united
states now some governors even from
states that do not share a border with
mexico have sent members of the national
guard to the u.s mexico border to assist
in border security mr lee you're first
with this question and you have 60
seconds to answer would you activate and
send nevada national guard troops to the
southern border
first off
that's a very good question every 15
days 275 000 people are coming across
the border into our country that's as
big as north las vegas is just so you
can get an understanding of what we're
creating we don't have the services we
don't have the schools we don't have the
health care to take care of all these
people i would put my
national guard people at risk
of
the state issues to send them down to
the border to see what we could do to
slow down what's going on with that
microgreen the the
the 42 thing we got to make sure that
people coming in here are not sick and
they come in legally but we need to stop
those migrants from coming they're going
to overwhelm us and our whole quality of
life is going to go down in the united
states thank you mr lee mr nora would
you activate and send national guard
troops to the southern border so as you
probably know my parents were legal
immigrants
and uh you know we went through the
rules and as do millions of people all
over the world that follow the rules
from everywhere whether it's africa or
asia or
latin america to come into this country
legally
the fact that our federal government
does not enforce
our border laws
is just horrifying to me
because
i seen people stand in line
everywhere i've seen how much how long
it takes
so it's just
as states
you know we're stuck with a federal
government that doesn't do their job
and to answer your question yes i would
send the
my
national guard out there
to help but that's just you know that's
just a band-aid we need to fix this
problem our federal government when i'm
governor every day the federal
government is going to hear from me hey
it's guinora from nevada fix this
problem you're killing us
thank you mr nora uh mr lombardo would
you activate and send nevada national
guard troops to the border no
there's a finite amount of money i was
actually a
military officer in the nevada national
guard there's a finite amount of money
associated with the deployment of your
local state guard
and if you deploy them to the border
that money would dry up quickly and it
would be prevent them from responding to
any crisis associated within the borders
of our state
what we need to do is force the hand of
the federal government obviously
immigration is a federal issue
we need to support within the state the
removal of individuals who have
committed crimes
and
present them to ice accordingly
i support
legal immigration i do not support
illegal immigration and i am the only
one standing up here at this podium that
has removed anybody who has committed
crimes associated with and being
undocumented illegal within the state of
nevada thank you mr lamar mr gilbert
same question to you would you deploy
troops to the southern border absolutely
without a doubt i would deploy the
troops but unfortunately sheriff
lombardo you know we refer to him among
us as sanctuary joe for a reason
department of justice inspector
general's report 2016 had clark county
is one of the worst sanctuary counties
in the nation on may 31st 2016 it was
labeled one of ten jurisdictions that
was found in violation of federal law
for not turning over illegal immigrants
to ice
now nevada has the highest illegal
immigrant population per capita in the
nation 223 000 we all know it's much
higher than that that's a direct you
know effect from not enforcing the law
and that took place right here since
2014 things have just been out of
control with regards to sanctuary city
it's exploded the crime rate by 500
percent so we have to do something if we
don't send you know help down to the
border it's going to continue to affect
us in a negative way we can't sustain it
what's going on here right now so we
absolutely must do something and i would
send our guard down there thank you mr
gilbert mr lombardo you were invoked
there for a minute uh 30 seconds to
reply is nevada is las vegas a sanctuary
city no sanctuary's determination comes
out of the state legislature and our
legislature has not identified or
labeled any jurisdiction within the
state of nevada's sanctuary
the removal of undocumented felonious
immigrants is done within the local
sheriff's jurisdiction and ability and
within southern nevada i do that on a
regular basis more so than any other
county in the state of nevada and it's
incumbent upon the resources available
via ice
and their ability to take those
individuals into custody and remove them
and the 500 percent
that is a fictitious number that mr
gilbert presented thank you mr lombardo
mr heller uh you're you have 60 seconds
to answer the full question would you
send nevada national guard troops to the
board i would but let's let's be clear
joe's not telling the truth here
what happened when he made southern
nevada a sanctuary city if you want to
live in a dangerous neighborhood live in
a sanctuary city and that's what this
guy costs you don't have to have the
legislature deem us a sanctuary city
what you do is you have a sheriff like
this guy that kicks ice out of metro and
not only does he do that he practices
catch and release
and those illegal immigrants that
committed crimes he's putting back on
the street
this is the problem that we have here in
southern nevada this guy needs to tell
the truth and actually own up to it we
have a 50 percent increase in homicides
we have a 45 percent increase in violent
crimes here in clark county all because
of this guy deciding that he wanted
southern nevada to be a sanctuary city
and this has to stop because it's
affecting everywhere else in the state
northern nevada washoe elko winnemaka
elko now has drugs and gangs because
this guy is bringing these illegal
immigrants into this state and spreading
them across the state thank you mr
heller again mr lombardo you've been uh
attacked uh
the the crime statistics are they
related to
the immigration issue absolutely not you
can't draw a line to the immigration
issue at all in the crime statistics and
as far as the homicide rate we are down
currently down three percent in totality
and homicide if you look at the joining
jurisdictions north las vegas and
henderson you can't say that and i have
not kicked ice out of our jail in our
system we present individuals from the
jail to ice
ice makes the determination whether they
take them what we did do is we got sued
by the aclu we lost the use of the
federal database to identify these
individuals and as a result we email
them and we make phone calls there is no
change in the procedures the national
picture has lacking the resources
associated for removal
thank you thank you mr water we'll we'll
have more time later in the debate but
our next question is denise we're going
to get to you in just a moment
gentlemen
now and then we'll come back during your
closing remarks you can go ahead and
come back to dr general's reports
available on my website gilbert all
right mr gilbert thank you so now moving
on to each candidate's